Lo que quiero hacer es empezar con una expresión como
4x más 18 y escribirla como una multiplicación de dos expresiones.
Básicamente lo que quiero hacer es
factorizar esta expresión y la clave aquí es ver si 4x y 18 tienen factores comunes,
y una vez que los encontremos, factorizarlos, utilizar algo así como el reverso de la propiedad distributiva y de esa forma
escribir a esta expresión como ese factor común por la suma de otros dos términos.
Entonces cuál es el número más grande que divide tanto a
4x como a 18, bueno de hecho,
en lugar de decir el número más grande debería yo decir la expresión más grande
pero en este caso esa expresión va a ser un solo número,
y veamos cuál es ese número.
Sabemos que el 2 divide al 4 y por lo tanto 2 también divide a 4 por "x"
y 2 también divide a 18,
entonces en esta expresión podemos factorizar un 2.
A ver este 4 lo podemos escribir como 2 por,
y ahora 4x entre 2 es
2x y este 18 lo podemos escribir como 2 por
9 ¿Ok? Entonces ya que escribimos
esta expresión de esta forma, podemos utilizar algo así como la propiedad
distributiva inversa, porque esto se parece muchísimo a lo que nos queda
cuando aplicamos la propiedad distributiva ¿No?
Entonces lo que vamos a hacer es agrupar este 2,
por aquí
y adentro de este paréntesis tiene que ir
2x, este 2x más 9, este 9.
¿Ok? Entonces si aplicamos la famosa propiedad distributiva,
lo que nos queda es 2 por 2x que es este término,
más 2 por 9 que es este término, y a su vez esta expresión es igual a esta expresión.
Entonces ya terminamos, ya escribimos a 4x más18
como el producto de dos expresiones, de 2 y de 2x más 9.
Entonces hagamos otro ejemplo.
Por ejemplo 12 más 32x,
aunque ¿Sabes qué? Mejor en lugar de usar la variable "x" vamos a usar la
variable "y" para tener un poco de diversidad, es exactamente lo mismo.
Estas dos son variables
simplemente las estamos llamando de otra forma y queremos factorizar esta expresión,
escribirla como un producto de dos expresiones.
Así es que tenemos que buscar cuál es la expresión más grande que divide tanto a 12
como a 32y, y bueno para empezar podemos ver
directamente que el 2 divide tanto a 12 como a 32y
porque el 2 divide a 32
pero, eso no es lo único.
A ver 12 lo podemos escribir como 4 por 3
y 32 es igual a 4 por 8,
así es que el 4 divide a ambos sumandos, y además es el máximo común divisor
entre 12 y 32 por que el 3 no divide a 32 y "y" tampoco divide a 12.
Entonces lo que vamos a hacer es factorizar ese 4 de esta expresión.
¿Ok? Este 12 lo podemos escribir como
4 por, y aquí lo que tiene que ir es un 3 y por acá este
32y lo podemos escribir como 4
por este 32y  entre 4, es igual a 8 por "y"
8y muy bien. Y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es aplicar la propiedad distributiva
inversa otra vez, o sea que vamos a agrupar este 4
y este 4 también, y lo que nos queda es 4
por este 3 más 8y,
8y ¿Ok? Si desarrollamos esta multiplicación nos queda por la propiedad distributiva 4 por 3
que es 12, más 4 por 8y que es 32y
y listo ya factorizamos esta otra expresión.